I really hate that so many predictions
have come true this week because of
what it means about the state of our democracy.
Before there was any victory to claim this week,
Donald Trump said at two a.m. on Friday. On
Tuesday night, early Wednesday morning that
he won the election. Then he started with the
claims that it was rigged about votes being
found, all claims which were flagged by Twitter
as potentially misleading about an election.
And now Donald Trump is starting with
lawsuits. The vote count resumed in
Pennsylvania yesterday. And as this was happening,
Donald Trump's personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
and Donald Trump's one of Donald Trump's sons,
Eric Trump, went to Philadelphia to announce
major action to stop the terrible cheating and
vote counting that was going on at the time.
It is not lost on me that in some cases
Donald Trump was saying we must stop counting
votes in other places. Donald Trump was saying
we must continue counting votes and so were his
supporters and will get to some of that video.
But first, Rudy Giuliani's explanation is
complete and total incoherence, saying that he
will file two lawsuits and a federal lawsuit
and maybe a national lawsuit. I can't even get
through this with a straight face. Take a look
at this and say that insanity. And I challenge you
to tell me what on earth is Rudy talking about?
A hundred thousand fraudulent, meaningless
paper ballots that no one gets to observe.
So we are going to continue the lawsuit
here. We're going to bring a second one
and then we're going to bring a federal lawsuit
and we're going to take a very good look at
whether we bring this nationally. We certainly
are going to bring it here. And in Wisconsin,
quite possibly, we'll do a national
lawsuit and really expose the corruption
of the Democrat Party. But this is beyond anything
I've ever seen before. This comes when you think
you have so much power and you own the media that
you can do anything you want. Well, sorry, we're
going to fight for the people. We're going to
vindicate their right. And the ultimate result is
President Trump has won Pennsylvania.
He's going to vindicate people. He's
filing for lawsuits. This is maybe Rudy Giuliani's
most humiliating moment. And I've seen the Borat
scene for people to be to understand. I'm
including that as well. It's a deranged person
making no sense or Trump put him up to it and he
feels like he can't say no. That's the only other
explanation I can imagine. So in an attempt to
tell you what is actually going on. And just as a
reminder, many times people say they are filing a
lawsuit and they don't. I'm just saying when Rudy
says on a whim, I'm filing two to four lawsuits,
let's verify that the lawsuits have actually been
filed. But the claim is that Trump's campaign is
filing lawsuits to stop the counting of ballots
in Michigan and Pennsylvania as they are demanding
increased access to observe the tallying process
at a bunch of locations in these key states. Trump
and the Georgia Republican Party have also filed a
lawsuit in Georgia. We don't know why. We don't
know for what. We don't yet know exactly who
they are suing. Their at least as of the time
that we went to record today. Maybe by now we
know what that lawsuit is about. The Trump
campaign also said that the lawsuit demands
that the Michigan lawsuit or the Pennsylvania
one or both demands that they want to review
ballots which were opened and counted without
them having meaningful access. And, of course,
what that means, we don't know now the
sort of funny thing or perverted thing,
depending on your perspective, is when
Trump announced that they were doing this,
he was losing Michigan and ultimately
Michigan was straight up called for Biden.
So my instinct, you might say, why would you stop
counting when you're losing, like in Michigan?
In Pennsylvania, he wants to stop counting while
he's winning. As of the time of that announcement,
my thought is the stop. The count is sort of an
intermediate measure meant to give them more time
to come up with something else, count the vote,
stop the count temporarily, and then figure out
what's the next claim that you're going to
make. But there was actually an even better
moment during this, and we caught it live during
my stream yesterday. And I want to get to that nex